саме глава держави це його
конституційний обов'язок по 106й статті
має подавати і вносити закони і поправки
до мобілізаційного законодавства ми
готові працювати зі змінами які
запропонує президент а не з тим мотлахом
яка нашкрябала одіозна депутатка За
завданням офісу президента і потім
соромно дивитися в очі і військовим і
цивільним лише
захист парламенту від подібного тиска
відновлення авторитету парламенту
сьогодні може захистити демократію І
тому ми вимагаємо по-перше повернути
журналістів в кулуари Верховної Ради
по-друге
відновити пряму трансляцію засідань нема
чого ховатися у нас під небезпекою
знаходиться Весь народ і тільки депутати
захищені відсутністю трансля ніхто вже в
це не вірить по-третє повернути годину
запитань до уряду Чому вони приходять
сюди лиж на лише на демонстрацію замість
того щоби парламент реалізовував
парламентський контроль
почетверте ухвалить законопроекти про
українську церкву про захист суб'єктів
господарювання після величезного
скандалу з бізнесом про захист
журналістів про захист громадських
діячів і припинить слідкування не лише
за журналістами а й за опозиційними
депутатами вистачить Слава Україні